[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Siebers ihnen
allen guten Abend die Welt aus neuer
Perspektive der Nordpol im Zentrum
umrahmt durch zwei olivenzweige das
Symbol für Frieden seit biblischen
Zeiten dieses Emblem auf hellblauem
Grund ist seit
1947 die Flagge für die gesamte
Menschheit geworden die
unolagge und auf der ganzen Welt in
Bangkok in Genf und hier in New York ist
diese Flagge heute auf Halbmast gesetzt
im Gedenken an die im Gazakrieg
getöteten Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeiter der Vereinten Nationen mehr
als 100 sind es bislang sagt das
unoilfswerk für palästinensische
Flüchtlinge
deren Kolleginnen und Kollegen bei der
UNO trauern heute mit einer
Schweigeminute in jedem Land ind dem es
eine UNO Vertretung
gibt die Gefechte gehen derwah weiter
mit schlimmen Folgen für Gaza auch das
Leid der dorthin verschleppten
israelischen Geiseln hat kein Ende
Stefan leifert aus Tel
Aviv am Alten Rathaus von Tel Aviv
erinnert seit heute Abend eine
wie die Zeit verrint sie ist den über
200 Geiseln gewidmet die nun seit über 5
Wochen in hamashand sind von über 5
Wochen Krieg ist der Gazastreifen
gezeichnet selbst vom grenzzun aus ist
das Ausmaß der Zerstörung zu erkennen
4300 Angriffe hat das israelische
Militär nach eigenen Angaben seit Beginn
der Offensive ausgeführt überwiegend
habe es sich um terroristische Ziele
gehandeltil die
Hamas en an den Orten öffentlichen
Lebens betreibt nimmt nun dort die
humanitäre Katastrophe ihren Lauf Bilder
aus einem Krankenhaus der Stadt kanjunis
nach einem Bombenangriff in der Umgebung
unter den Opfern immer wieder
Kinder wir wissen nicht was passiert ist
der Angriff traf uns plötzlich als wir
einfach da saßen wir saßen auf der
Straße und dann kam der
Angriff Israels Militär veröffentlicht
heute Bilder die zeigen sollen wie sich
Terroristen mit Panzerfäusten im alkutz
Krankenhaus verschanzen es kam zu
Kämpfen bei denen 21 Terroristen nach
Armeeangaben getötet wurden in einem
Haus im Norden des Gazastreifens fanden
die Soldaten laut einem Video ein
Waffenlager der Terrororganisation
islamischer
Jihad wir haben viele Waffen gefunden
kampfwesten und Uniformen und daneben
standen Fotos von iranischen
Führer die von israelsarmee
veröffentlichten Bilder sollen vom
Fortschritt der Bodenoffensive Zeugen
dieas habe die olle über den
Gazastreifen verloren gibt sich israels
Regierung heute siegesgewiss premier
netanahu irgendwo zwischen
Siegesgewissheit und
Durchhalteparolen wir werden gewinnen es
gibt keine Pausen wir machen keine
halben Sachen das hier ist nicht
irgendeine Operation oder eine weitere
Runde wir kämpfen bis zum endgültigen
Sieg Gazas krankenhäuser werden immer
mehr zum Drama im Drama dieses Kriegs
die humanitäre Situation eine he immer
mehr Patienten werden aus den
Krankenhäusern des Nordens nach Süden
gebracht wir haben unser Kind erst ins
Krankenhaus in jabalia gebracht dann
musste es wegen der schweren
Kopfverletzung ins alschifer Krankenhaus
dort konnten wir auch nicht bleiben nun
sind wir hier im
Süden Zerstörung auf der anderen Seite
der Grenze der kibut ASA war bis zum 7
oktober für 700 Menschen ein zuause auch
für K heutert sie zum ersten Mal zurück
aells Mann wurde von den Terroristen
erschossen heute sucht sie nach ein paar
Sachen die an ihn
erinnern ich bin gekommen um ein paar
Pflanzen aus meinem Garten zu holen und
ein paar Dinge die mein Mann so
liebte er hatte eine besondere Tasse und
seinen
Schlüsselbund ich bin froh dass ich
hergekommen bin aber es ist so
schwer 18 Menschen aus dem kibutz sind
noch als Geiseln in den Händen der Hamas
seit über 5 Wochen nun die Installation
in Tel Aviv erinnert daran wie quälend
die Zeit
verrinmt wenn ausgerechnet Krankenhäuser
im Zentrum stehen von Kämpfen und
gegenseitigen Beschuldigungen dann sagt
das viel über die Gnadenlosigkeit eines
Krieges in Gaza sind die Orte an denen
die Verwundeten und verwundbarsten Hilfe
und Hoffnung finden sollten zum
Brennpunkt geworden Israels Armee
beschuldigt Hamas mit voller Absicht
exakt dort tief unter der Erde ihre
Kommandozentralen platziert zu haben
Hamas meldet jeden Tag neue Tote und
Verletzte infolge israelischer Angriffe
wer in Gazas Krankenhäusern Schutz und
Heilung suchte spürt die Folgen und die
sind verheerend nach unoangaben ist die
Hälfte aller Kranken in Gaza
mittlerweile geschlossen Wolf Christian
Ulrich hat die Bilder unserer BBC
Kollegin a garen und des Kollegen Jeremy
B
zusammengestellt sie tragen immer neue
verwundete in die Krankenhäuser so die
den noch funktionieren unterwegs im
Süden von Gaza hier soll es sicherer
sein doch auch hier ist
Krieg ein Riesenkrater wo eigentlich ein
Schutzraum sein sollte unter den
Trümmern R verschüttete nach Hilfe
Helfer versuchen Kinder zu
retten Samira ist aus dem Schifer
Krankenhaus in Gaza City nach Süden
geflohen wir dachten das Krankenhaus sei
sicher aber das war es nicht während wir
5 Minuten länger geblieben wären wir
umgekommen mein Sohn ist verletzt ich
habe ihn dort
gelassen dort vor dem Schifer
Krankenhaus liegen die Leichen vor der
Tür in den Fluren liegen die Verletzten
harren Flüchtlinge aus es gibt kein
frisches Wasser mehr kein Essen und
inzwischen auch keinen Strom Frühchen
kämpfen ohne Inkubator um ihr Leben
manche vergebens im Gebäude vermutet das
israelische Militär Kämpfer der Hamas
auch im alkutz Krankenhaus ist der Strom
ausgefallen ärzte operieren beim Schein
von
Taschenlampen das Leid ist groß doch
einfache Antworten so zeigt sich hier
gibt es nicht israelische Soldaten
führen Journalisten durch apokalyptische
trümmerlandschaften das sind die Tunnel
in denen sich Terroristen der Hamas
verschanzen was aussieht wie ein
Kinderzimmer so eine Hamas Waffenfabrik
gewesen sein die Schutzschilde der
Terroristen sind israelische Geiseln und
Palästinenser unser Geheimdienst kennt
die Ziele wir wissen wen wir treffen
mein Kommandeur hat die Ziele
freigegeben ich versuche mit aller Kraft
wirklich nur den Feind zu
treffen wenn man sich die Zerstörung
hier ansieht ist der Feind überall sagt
der
Reporter diese jungen israelischen
Soldaten gehen in den gefährlichen
Häuserkampf und sie erzählen es sei ihn
egal wie lange der Krieg dauert jeder
kenne jemanden den die Hamas entführt
oder ermordet
hat und Palästinenser aus dem Norden
fliehen weiter Richtung Süden auch ihnen
sitzt der Schrecken von Bomben und Tod
tief in den
Knochen
die Geschichte wird uns das nicht
verzeihen sagt heute der scheidende
Außenminister von Luxemburg auf seinem
letzten eu-ministertreffen Jean
Asselborn hat viel erlebt in seiner
Karriere das unendliche Leid das in
Israel geschehen sei dürfe sich nicht in
Gaza wiederholen sagt er es stimme zwar
dass Hamas Krankenhäuser als
Schutzschilde nutze aber man müsse
dennoch den Mut haben den Freunden in
Israel zu sagen dass man
Hilfsorganisationen wie Ärzte ohne
Grenzen zuhören müsse und die fordern
dass die Kämpfe an den Krankenhäusern
stoppen auch US-Präsident Biden sagt
heute das schiferhospital müsse
geschützt werden Frage an unseren
Reporter und Korrespondenten in Israel
Michael bwerunge Michael wie kommt denn
das bei israels Regierung
an du hast es gerade ja gesagt Christian
die israelische Armee vermutet unter dem
schiferhospital das Hauptquartier der
Hamas in Gaza und das Ziel ist auf jeden
Fall dieses Hauptquartier einzunehmen
die Armee betont immer wieder das
Hospital habe damit nichts zu tun sei
überhaupt nicht das Ziel man würde sich
bemühen eine Evakuierung zu erleichtern
man habe sogar Sprit und Treibstoff
angeboten das hab die die hab m aber
verhindert also es gibt keinen Zweifel
daran dass Israel auf jeden Fall dieses
Hauptquartier einnehmen will
interessanterweise wurde heute Abend vom
Armeesprecher ein Video sehr intensiv
vorgestellt dass das rantisi
Kinderhospital zeigen soll das wurde
offenbar jedenfalls nach armeeangab mit
Hilfe der Armee geräumt und im Keller
quasi das gesamte basement war eine
hamasinrichtung wo möglicherweise sogar
Geiseln kindergeiseln gehalten worden
sein sollen wie die Bilder nahlegen und
die Botschaft ist natürlich ganz Klar
seht her das ist das rantisi Hospital
aber im schiferhospital ist die Hamas
Infrastruktur noch viel schlimmer jetzt
sagt Israels Verteidigungsminister Hamas
habe die Kontrolle in Gaza verloren
woran genau macht er das denn fest
Galland hat gesagt dass hamaskämpfer in
großer Zahl in den Süden fliehen sollen
woran er das festmacht können wir auch
nicht nachvollziehen weil eigentlich ist
ja der Landweg gestoppt ob das dann in
Tunneln stattfindet oder nicht wissen
wir nicht und er sagt dass
Basen der Hamas von Flüchtlingen
geplündert wurden auch das können wir
nicht überprüfen aber was schon deutlich
ist dass diese Bodenoffensive der
Israelis mit großer Geschwindigkeit und
offenbar unter nicht so großen Verlusten
erfolgt die Israelis Veröffentlicher im
Gegensatz zu Hamas immer die Namen und
die Zahl ihrer getöteten Soldaten also
es gibt natürlich auch verlist Verluste
aber die Armee scheint sich doch
ziemlich schnell um Gasa zu bewegen und
den Ring zuzuziehen die Information aus
Israel von Michael bwerunge vielen dank
Michael der Nahostkrieg beschäftigt auch
die Innenpolitik auch in Deutschland in
Großbritannien heute mit akut guten
folgen dort hatte die Innenministerin
Demonstrationen bei denen eine
Waffenruhe für Gaza gefordert wurde
pauschal als hassmärsche bezeichnet
ihrer eigenen Polizei warf sie eine
Doppelmoral vor man muss Hal heute sagen
es ist die exinnenministerin denn
suellaa Braverman ist wegen dieser und
anderer Kontroversen heute entlassen
worden premier risunak versucht einen
Befreiungsschlag angesichts mieser
Umfrage Werte und holt einen alten
Bekannten zurück auf die große
Politbühne nämlich seinen vor vor vor
Vorgänger einer der mal Regierungschef
war wird jetzt Außenminister Hilke
Petersen zurück in die Zukunft so ein
Moment war das als vor Downing Street 10
der vor vor vor Vorgänger des
amtierenden Premierminister sunak seinem
Auto entsteigt David Cameron ist seit
heute morgen britischer
Außenminister das ist ein toalerock
Stimmung in Westminster heute
Verblüffung Verwirrung hysterisches
Lachen wir wissen nicht wirklich was um
alles in der Welt ist
los ich weiß es ist nicht üblich für
einen früheren Regierungschef in dieser
Weise zurückzukommen aber ich glaube an
den Dienst am Land der Premierminister
fragte mich und wir haben einige
beunruhigende Herausforderungen vor uns
wie den nostkonflikt und den in der
Ukraine sunak versucht einen die
Kabinettsumbildung soll ihm aus dem
Umfragetief helfen vor den Wahlen im
kommenden Jahr etwas seltsam mutet das
an hat er doch gerade neulich auf dem
Parteitag die Abkehr von 30 Jahren
konservativen Politikstil ausgerufen nun
ausgerechnet Cameron der gilt als
Urheber des brexit tritt 2016 nach der
Abstimmung
zurück legendär sein Abgang damals
gescheitert nach dem jah zum EU-Austritt
Cameron aber nm es
beschwingt
doch immerhin tritt mit Cameron einer an
der international einen Namen und
Erfahrung hat zu China hat er umstritten
gute dräte und damit er ein
Problem es war der Rauswurf von
Innenministerin suella bravan der sunak
heute Zwang lauter Posten neu zu
besetzen die
rechtsaußenkonservative ist bekannt für
die Lust am provozieren zuletzt hatte
sie die proalästinensischen Proteste der
vergangenen Wochen hassmärsche genannt
und die eigene Polizei bezichtigt nicht
durchzugreifen bravan hat Rockstar
Qualitäten im rechten Parteiflügel sunak
dürfte mehr erger mit ihr
drohen sie wird von den hinterbänken aus
gegen den Premierminister stenkern und
jede Menge Leute um sich scharen vom
rechtsaußenflügel in sunx Downing Street
brennt heute die Luft der neue
Innenminister war eben noch
Außenminister James cleverly er muss für
Sun jetzt die heikle Flüchtling
Steuern noch mehr ministerpersonal geht
rein und wieder raus ein großer
jobtausch das im aktiven Kabinett kein
veritabler Außenminister zu finden war
legen viele sunak als schwächer
aus so beim Thema Nahost bleibst du
jetzt noch ein Moment Hanna in der
Nachrichtenübersicht ja auch die EU
außenministerinnen und Minister haben
heute in Brüssel über die Lage im Nahen
Osten beraten und in einer gemeinsamen
Erklärung sofortige Feuerpausen
gefordert um im Gas Streifen humanitäre
Korridore zu schaffen unein sind die
Mitgliedstaaten dagegen bei einer
längeren Waffenruhe diese fordert unter
anderem Frankreich Deutschland ist
dagegen der
euaußenbeauftragte Borell kündigte an
noch diese Woche zu Gesprächen in die
Region zu
reisen die Deutschen Aktivisten von
Fridays for future haben sich ein
weiteres Mal von propalästinensischen
Aussagen Greta thünbergs distanziert mit
ihrer Positionierung verletze thünberg
gerade viele Menschen schrieb Fridays
for future Deutschland auf einer
klimaschutzdemo in Amsterdam hatte die
schwedische klimaaktivistin erneut
einseitig Partei für die Palästinenser
ergriffen und skandierte unter anderem
auf besetztem Land gebe es keine
Klimagerechtigkeit seit Wochen wird
tünberg vorgeworfen die Opfer des Hamas
Terrors zu
ignorieren vor allem im Norden
Deutschlands wurde heute in vielen
Landesämtern Kliniken oder auch Schulen
gestreigt die Gewerkschaft wä hatte die
Beschäftigten des öffentlichen Dienstes
der Länder dazu aufgerufen ihre Arbeit
niederzulegen Ziel ist im Tarifstreit
den Druck zu erhöhen die dritte
Verhandlungsrunde steht im Dezember an
die Gewerkschaften fordern eine
Lohnerhöhung von 10,5% im Monat
mindestens aber 500 €
mehr die beiden spdvorsitzenden Saskia
esken und Lars Klingbeil wollen erneut
als Doppelspitze der SPD kandidieren im
spd- Präsidium gaben sie heute bekannt
dass sie sich beim Bundesparteitag im
Dezember für weitere zwei Jahre als
Parteivorsitzende zur Wiederwahl stellen
wollen esken ist seit 2019 im Amt
Klingbeil seit Ende
2021 die weltweite plastikverschmutzung
ist seit heute Thema von
un-verhandlungen in Kenias Hauptstadt
Nairobi Vertreter aus mehr als 170
Staaten beraten über konkrete Maßnahmen
um den Plastikmüll einzudämmen das
Abkommen soll weltweit blich sein es
handelt sich um die dritte von fünf
Verhandlungsrunden nach Angaben des
europäischen Verbands der
kunststofferzeuger wurden 2022 weltweit
400 Millionen Tonnen Kunststoff
produziert das ist doppelt so viel wie
über 17 000 Kinder unter 14 Jahren als
Opfer sexuellen Missbrauchs das sind die
Zahlen aus dem vergangenen Jahr in
Deutschland und es sind nur die
offiziell erfassten Fälle 17
tausendfaches leid die meisten Täter
seinen den betroffenen Kindern vertraut
und nutzten dieses Vertrauen aus sagt
die Bundesfamilienministerin heute eine
bundesweite Kampagne soll dafür sorgen
dass mehr Erwachsene Verantwortung
übernehmen besser Hinsehen zuhören
Nachfragen dass sie auf Signale achten
die auf einen sexuellen Missbrauch bei
Kindern hindeuten können auch und gerade
im Internet wie Heike slanski
berichtet das Kind zu Hause im
vermeintlich sicheren Hafen tatsächlich
unterwegs im Netz vielleicht in
Chaträumen wo jeder mit jedem
kommunizieren kann ohne zu wissen wer
sich dahinter verbirgt welche intenionen
verfolgt werden wenn Kinder über Portale
sei es über Spieleportale sei es über
tiktok sei es über Instagram mit anderen
Personen Kontakt treten die wiederum von
ihnen dann Nacktbilder haben wollen oder
sogar Abbildung von pornographischen
Handl
dann ist es eine große
Gefährdung noch nie wurde so hemmungslos
gechattet in 0 kom nichts werden
unangemessene Aufforderungen verschickt
Beispiel aus einer
Ermittlungsakte wie alt bist du noch mal
werde im Oktober
12 schick mal Pussi wir haben meen sehr
starken Anstieg der Fälle von Weitergabe
oder runterladen von Abbildung von
sexuellen Missbrauch da haben wir eine
Verfünffachung der Zahlen in den letzten
Jahren und wir sehen weitere Anstiege
cybergrooming der Fachbegriff Erwachsene
die sich als gleichaltrige ausgeben und
sexuelle Kontakte zu Minderjährigen
suchen zu viele Jugendliche sind arglos
lassen sich leicht manipulieren geben
aus freien Stücken ihre Handynummer
Preis für Täter und Täterinnen ist das
Smartphone das ultimative
tmittel weil mit dem Smartphone bin ich
immer bei dir egal was du machst egal
wohin du gehst ich bin auch da und das
bedeutet ich kann die mitten in der
Nacht aufwecken und sagen schick mir mal
irgendein nackbild von dir experten
warnen das Netz macht Kinder und
Jugendliche zunehmend zum Freiwild kaum
Beschränkungen wenig Kontrollen keiner
der sofort helfen könnte haben Sie schon
mal im Netz eine virtuelle
Polizeistreife gesehen vermutlich nicht
weder Täter haben das gesehen noch die
Kinder nicht und das wirft die Frage auf
wie können sich eigentlich Kinder in
einem digitalen Raum wenn ihen etwas
passiert an die polizeiwenden in den
digitalen Räumen kann mir alles begegnen
vom knutsch Video bis hin zur harten
Pornografie und ich möchte noch mal
festhalten es ist in Deutschland
verboten Minderjährigen unter 18 Jahren
Pornografie zugänglich zu machen wenn
das im digitalen Raum geschieht sagen
alle so ein bisschen ja ist halt so
Tatort Internet ein globaler
Kommunikationsraum mit entsetzlichen
Risiken für Kinder und Jugendliche erst
recht wenn sie nicht darauf vorbereitet
sind weitere Informationen dazu
Ansprechpartner und Adressen gibt es
auch im Netz im Internet unter folgender
Adresse Hilfe bportal
bmissbrauch.de jetzt noch mal du Hanna
ja und zwar mit aus der Wirtschaft schon
länger ist der Energiekonzern Siemens
Energy schwer angeschlagen doch jetzt
soll das Unternehmen offenbar
Staatsgarantien in Milliardenhöhe
erhalten das berichten mehrere Medien
überereinstimm Stephanie Barrett um wie
viel Geld geht es dem Naach genau und
wie wichtig sind diese Garantien für
Siemens Energy also so wie es aussieht
steht jetzt ein stützungspaket über 15
Milliarden Euro den weitaus größten
Brocken an Garantien übernehmen dabei
die Banken der Bund springt nur im
Notfall für gut die Hälfte dieser
Garantien ein und für den Rest soll der
Mutterkonzern Siemens aufkommen darauf
hatte ja im Vorfeld schon der Bund
gepocht in diesem Fall fiel die Hilfe
dem Bund auch leichter weil es sich eben
nicht um eine direkte Staatsbeteiligung
handelt wie etwa bei der Rettung des
gashändlers uniper Siemens Energy
benötigt die Garantien dringend um seine
Großaufträge für den Bau von
Stromleitungen und Windkraftanlagen in
den kommenden Jahren zu finanzieren das
Unternehmen gilt ja als wichtiger Akteur
der Energie Wende warum ist der Konzern
überhaupt so in Schieflage geraten ja
Siemens Energy sitzt zwar auf einem
Auftragsbestand von satten 110
Milliarden Euro hat aber massive
Qualitätsprobleme bei seiner
windkrafttochter Siemens Gamesa die seit
Jahren schon Verluste schreibt und die
Konzernbilanz von Siemens Energy
belastet dazu herrscht noch ein ruinöser
Preiskampf der die Gewinne schmelzen
lässt fast alle Anbieter von
windkraftturbinen schreiben deshalb rote
Zahlen dennoch nach dem
verhandlungsdurch Bruch legte die Aktie
hier in Frankfurt heute deutlich zu der
Kurs stieg um 6%. letzte Details der
komplexen Einigung soll nun am Mittwoch
bei Vorlage der Jahresbilanz von Siemens
Energy in München verkündet werden viel
Dank Stefanie für deine
Einschätzung laut dem Drogenbeauftragten
der Bundesregierung blinard sind
Millionen Deutsche spielsüchtig oder
davon gefährdet das geht aus dem
sogenannten Glücksspiel Atlas 2023
hervor demnach leiden rund 1,3 Millionen
Erwachsene an einer sogenannten
glücksspielstörung weitere 3,3 Millionen
zeigten ein riskantes Spielverhalten mit
Anzeichen zur Sucht einen starken
Zuwachs gibt es bei den
Sportwetten Tennisprofi alexander zwev
hat sein Auftaktspiel beim
Saisonabschlussturnier den ATP Finals in
Turin gewonnen der Weltranglisten siebte
siegte gegen Carlos alcaras aus Spanien
in drei Sätzen weitere Gegner zevs in
der Gruppenphase sind die Russen Daniel
medwedjev und Andrej
rjov es gibt eine amtliche
Unwetterwarnung des Deutschen
Wetterdienstes und zwar vor ergiebigem
Dauerregen in Teilen von Bayern und
BadenWürttemberg folgessen kann es unter
anderem zu Hochwasser an wächen und
kleineren Flüssen sowie Überflutungen
von Straßen kommen auf der italienischen
Mittelmeerinsel Sizilien ist Europas
höchster aktiver Vulkan der Etna wieder
ausgebrochen am Sonntagabend spuckte der
etedner große Mengen glühende Lava in
den Himmel die Säule aus Gasen und
flüssigem Gestein reichte bis in eine
Höhe von 4,5 km so italienische
Wissenschaftler auf umliegende Orte ging
Asche Regen nieder größere Schäden gab
es aber wohl nicht inzwischen hat sich
der etner
beruhigt also der ner auf Sizilien hat
sich erstmal wieder beruhigt auf Island
ist das Gegenteil der Fall dort tut sich
etwas ell gewaltiges seit Ende Oktober
gab es mehr als 25 000 Erdbeben und der
Katastrophenschutz rechnet jetzt mit
einem bevorstehenden vulkanusbruch wir
erleben eine der bedeutendsten
geologischen Sequenzen seit vielen
Jahrzehnten sagen die Geologen und die
wissen das heißt was denn auf Island
rumpelt es ständig irgendwo 1973 bildete
sich eine 3 km lange Erdspalte aus der
100 Kubik gespuckt wurden und zwar jede
Sekunde diesmal könnte es schlimmer
werden Henner Hebestreit ist auf
Island ein Vulkan brodelt tief unten in
der Erde bei grinderwig plötzlich tun
sich Abgründe auf wo vorher Menschen
gelaufen und Autos gefahren waren
vielleicht sind es die letzten Tage
dieser Stadt viele der 3500 Einwohner
sind noch einmal in ihre geräumte Heimat
gekommen
ihnen witig ist die Natur könnte ihnen
schon bald zeigen wer der Stärkere ist
darüber reden sie viel in der
hallgrimskirche von rejawig wo sie sich
treffen und gegenseitig Beistand
geben wir mussten grindg evakuieren
wegen einer möglichen vulkanischen
Eruption in unmittelbarer
nachtbarssta wir haben das geschafft und
ich bin unendlich dankbar dass niem Verl
wurde ist was immer passiert das wird
doch immer unser Ziel bleiben denn wir
können die Kräfte der Natur nicht
kontrollieren aber wir können
kontrollieren wie wir darauf
reagieren deshalb haben die Behörden
grinderweg auch nur für einen Nachmittag
geöffnet jeder der hiermit vollgepacktem
Wagen unterwegs ist wurde ständig
beobachtet und zur schnellen Abreise
gedrängt
es ist eine schier endlose Blechkarawane
die sich da aus grinderwig herauswindet
für ein paar Stunden hatten die Menschen
noch mal Gelegenheit nach Hause zu gehen
und das zusammen zuaffen was sie
irgendwie greifen können und jetzt
wollen sie nichts wie weg aus der
Gefahrenzone wir müssen Platz machen und
treffen Menschen die mit ihrer
bisherigen Heimat abgeschlossen
haben es war eine Erleichterung ein paar
Sachen holen zu können aber ich möchte
keinesfalls wieder dort wohnen ich habe
ein kleines Kind und hatte zuletzt immer
riesige
Angst ich möchte hier nicht mehr wohnen
wenn es nach mir ginge sollte der Vulkan
ausbrechen und alles
[Musik]
Z so fatalistisch sind nur wenige hier
die meisten haben die Autos voll gepackt
und bringen ihr habp und gut in
Sicherheit weil alle unter großem Stress
stehen hält der Katastrophenschutz mit
Drohnen die Lage im
Blick wir gucken wie der Verkehr fließt
und sind ständig mit der Polizei in
Kontakt und sagen Bescheid wenn etwas
passiert er meint die Straße aber was so
viele hier in Bewegung hält ist die
Angst vor der Entwicklung tief unten in
der Erde bei
grinderwig wir werden diese Erde weiter
im Blick behalten für heute danke dass
Sie bei uns waren ja und um kurz vor
Mitternacht begrüßt sie dann hier nasand
gckte mir mit unserem heute journal
Update von uns allen hier in Redaktion
Produktion und hier im Studio ein
angenehmen Abend
[Musik]
tschüss guten Abend das Tief Jasper
liegt morgen Mittag hier über Dänemark
und es bringt viel Wind mit zum einen
über den Bergen also über den
Alpengipfeln z.B aber auch in den
Mittelgebirgen in Norddeutschland vor
allen Dingen aber auch über der Nordsee
und dieses Tief Jasper bringt auch viel
Regen mit dieses Tief zieht ja bis
morgen Abend weiter bis zur ostse und
auch an den Alpen Regen des ergiebig im
Schwarzwald hat es bis heute morgen etwa
60 l Regen pro Quadratmeter innerhalb
von 24 Stunden gegeben und bis morgen
Abend kommen in Süddeutschland noch mal
30 bis 60 l dazu es gibt also ergiebigen
Dauerregen heute Nacht hier im
Süddeutschland im Norden gibt's auch
Regenfälle aber zwischen der Eifel und
der lauses bleibt es am ehesten trocken
die Temperaturen dazu sinken auf 13° am
oberrein und bis 5° an der Ostsee und
morgen erwarten uns dann
Höchsttemperaturen von 9° in den
östlichen Mittelgebirgen und 14° in der
Lausitz im rheinmineebiet oder auch am
oberreim und morgen regnet es weiter
besonders hier in Süddeutschland und
immer noch gibt es diesen liebigen
Dauerregen auch in Norddeutschland an
den Küsten werden Sie kaum mal die Sonne
zu Gesicht bekommen da zieht ja genau
das Tief drüber etwas freundlicher sieht
es aus hier Richtung Thüringen und
Sachsen da bleibt es wohl am ehesten
trocken da kann sich auch mal die Sonne
zeigen an diesem Wetter ändert sich am
Mittwoch wenig am Donnerstag wird's
ruhiger und der Freitag wird kälter mit
Höchsttemperaturen von nur noch 5 bis
10° ich wünsche dir noch einen schönen
Abend